so when you first came across bitcoin
you already had kind of this
um this mental framework to think about
digital assets digital currencies
uh other folks like jesse powell et
cetera i think very similarly they've
been doing things in video games and and
so when they saw this
uh it just kind of fit into this world
view what was it for you because i think
you were into gold
uh quite a bit beforehand then when you
saw bitcoin was there one or two
specific things we were like bam this is
it like this is going to
work this time well a couple of things
so
i i kind of quickly figured out that
this was a new asset class you know
i started my career in the 80s as a
stock broker so
i'm sensitive to looking at asset
classes and what is an asset class with
bitcoin
is it a stock is it a bond is it a
commodity you know where does it fit as
an asset class and then you realize that
it's actually a new asset class
and if that's true then the world money
management
which is huge you know there's a hundred
trillion dollars worth of funds looking
for
investment you know if they get into
this it's going to be
huge uh the second thing is my
background in digital currencies in
gaming
uh back in the 90s i know that virtual
currencies
to the mind of people online there's no
differentiation between a digital
currency and anything else it's it's
money
to anyone who's in the gaming world in
the 1990s uh you know you once you get
into it
whether it's second life which had the
linden dollar or
the world of witchcraft had gold swords
and things like that once you
you cross over your mind starts thinking
about this and
in that way you just adopted his money
so i knew that people
would ex would accept this as money so
he put those things together and then
the price
action just keeps going up so that's
that number go up technology and it
keeps
you keep going down the rabbit hole
keeps push pulling you down the rabbit
hole even today
at these prices i'm you know we're still
stacking sets because it's just
it just seems like the only logical
thing you can do it's like a bulwark
against the insanity that's going on in
the world
you know in washington and elsewhere
when you stack sets it's like a
calming thing that you do to ground
yourself in the satoshi
bitcoin reality so one of the things
that's fascinating to me
is uh most people know you for all of
the crazy antics people have seen the
videos of you
ripping up the 10 bill or at the bitcoin
conference uh yelling and screaming
with michael saylor et cetera right
which as i've gotten to know you i think
is uh part of the magic of max and stacy
but when you think about it from a pure
investment standpoint
uh most great investors would tell you
that
in order to be great you have to cut
your losers faster than anyone
and you have to press your winners
harder than anyone else so from a pure
capital allocation standpoint
you all started buying bitcoin at a
dollar and have continued to buy
since then now the reason why i bring
that up is because there's a lot of
people
who discovered bitcoin early on maybe
they didn't have the conviction to buy a
lot
or along the way they said hey i bought
it at a dollar it went to five dollars
then they sold it and so
what is the thing that has kept you kind
of so convicted to not only
see it early and have the conviction
that this could work but also to ride
the most volatile asset over the last
decade to what became the best
performing asset over the last decade as
well
yeah you know and bitcoin is uh it has
the ability to
work on you that the investor in
many different ways and part of it is
psychological and
part of it is just from a pure money
management perspective
uh how much do you want to allocate how
much do you want to go into this
and as you get deeper into it you
realize that
other people that are talking about it
their arguments are terrible
and that adds to my conviction so for
example i don't want to go on a huge
peter schiff diatribe here but
his arguments are terrible and he i told
peter to buy it i sat down with him at
his
house in connecticut for a couple hours
and walked him through it when bitcoin
was
under 10 dollars and every single year
since then over 10 years he still
he mentally can't get into it and when i
see somebody like that
you know i'm open to any argument
against bitcoin you know i listen to
everybody every single day give me the
argument against it
and every time i hear something i know
it's it doesn't work the fud
it never works and it just increases my
conviction
and it increases the the idea of what is
the total addressable market of
this asset class you know and certainly
michael saylor's done a great job in
saying
you know that melting ice cube on the
balance sheet you look at the corporate
world there's trillions of dollars
you look at the money management world
there's trillions of more dollars
you look at it versus gold and is it
going to capture part or all of gold
is monetization that's a 9 to 10
trillion dollar market cap
yeah that that's all happening so the
price is still cheap and then
as a money manager you know you figure i
gotta own it you gotta keep nibbling at
it it's still
cheap bitcoin at this price is still
incredibly cheap
hey guys thanks so much for watching
that clip of the best business show make
sure you like and subscribe to the
channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday
and then head to sofi.com so that you
can get an account
we can get after it